goddamn uh what's-his-name oh why in NW
Mele okay so what's the deal I didn't
read the core case so I I read the
summary alright and I was still a little
confused on the summary but basically
what I had gathered is that he had his
phone on him the whole time yeah so the
phone was pinging everywhere he was at
ok so it like gave away pretty much that
he was in the car
yeah or his phone was yeah ok and and
there's some snapchat messages or
something I didn't see that someone said
to they go yes they got his stamp
snapchat messages and his text messages
or maybe it's just the snapchat me okay
either way they got all that [ __ ] and so
I went back cuz after it was released I
he killed his friends I'm like ok I want
to let this marinate a little bit let
more facts come out and then I'll go
listen to murder on my mind ok and you
go listen to murder on my mind and it
just is so weirdly specific did he make
that song after yes he did
yeah and so what what are the lyrics
like what like he's got a line in there
about like putting two shots in somebody
and holding them and they say I don't
want to die and he tells him it's too
late oh it's like like you did that bro
and I could be wrong but it's my
understanding that like him and his
buddy
killed his boy he's like in the car and
then they went outside the car and shot
it to me yeah it was a driver that's
great just like wow like pulled it out
and just like ah captain in the car come
on dawg I wonder why that's the part I
don't get
cuz like there wasn't it maybe I didn't
read enough but there's no mention of
like if like Y&W was like it's not like
a gang like right like wasn't it just
like some it's like I took a rap group
yeah yeah yeah like a rap collective
yeah like like ybn yeah it's so
man is dark it's [ __ ] dark man cuz
then it goes afterwards and makes music
about it and post on his again he's like
not convicted but the court Doc's
I mean it's pretty kind of and damning
pretty damning but [ __ ] you know well
how is it what's the video like for
murder on my mind I didn't watch dudes
grads graphic is [ __ ] is it what is it's
like holding someone dying in the street
how could you do that
how did you act out what you did if it's
all true you gotta be [ __ ] sick man
I mean he's it makes a video a lot
creepier and it's not one of those
things where I'm like surprised like a
gangster rapper
does bad [ __ ] it's not like that it's
like the premeditated aspect of it and
like it's it's not like he's in a gang
and like he's rapping him about like how
he shot people up and then you know cuz
like if you're in a gang and you shoot
rival gang members and all that that's
like I don't know you
there's a lot that goes into that like
to come from that world you know
socioeconomic [ __ ] you can understand
why it's is horrible but like you
understand why someone would do it but
this is just like he's like some Ted
Bundy [ __ ] like just the only thing I
read that could have been like a motive
is that he was getting bullied by one of
the dudes or something yeah yeah yeah
and I guess Toby I put it in those terms
yeah what the [ __ ] is the motive why I
don't get that maybe he's just like he
was doing market research for a song
that he was writing got to him too I
mean like dude it's crazy like murder
people and then go write a song about
murder and have it just be the biggest
hit like 100 million views on YouTube or
some [ __ ] yeah yeah it's [ __ ] is a
here it's a huge song what that's crazy
it really is that's crass I mean this is
actually legitimately crazy though like
insane crazy not like it's [ __ ] I mean
I could own it and I guess if you put it
in that context like if this dude is
really like really on his ass and like
really trying them and like being like
you're soft you're small you're not
about it then just don't kill him I'm
but you know what I mean yeah it like it
can get to that point yes
unfollow him you know gonna fall yeah
block him you know gotta kill the guy I
know I know
yeah block um that's even a little
extreme yeah that's fine don't come ya
know I mean I'm not condoning murder
okay I don't want someone to twist my
words I'm not saying like okay I get it
if you get bullied ya kill him I'm not
saying that I guess I'm just trying oh
yeah I think you said that dude I mean I
did say that you were saying that yeah
no no well Miller condones murder damn
it dude
oh man I'm just saying like if you're in
a gang and he was like you know
something like he grew up with and it's
like he's from a set and it's like a
long-standing beef and he got caught
shooting someone from a rival gang you
know I I get why what happened but the
bullying part I could I could understand
why someone would get pushed to that
point but [ __ ] it should not come to
that man so if he's convicted he goes to
jail for like ever
I think so yeah man that's so crazy
it really is man it really is like man I
don't know I just feel like you know
like having a successful career in music
is so rare it is
and then also murdering someone and
going to jail for life is also pretty
rare too so to do both to do both in
like two months of each other this crazy
cheese this is all I'm gonna say it's
crazy
it's tragic too yeah it's [ __ ] oh
yeah tragic I mean just don't kill
people yeah it just doesn't need to have
him in just hot take right there murder
is bad yeah you can quote me on that
don't kill people yeah definitely don't
kill people that's that's that's me so
don't kill me don't kill people just
don't do it
just stop killing people man knock it
off knock it off
not trying to flex and I'm holding half
this Bank I'm trying to flex not trying
to flex take your vision notion break
that's not a flex